We'll be safe here
for a minute.
Take off that wet jumpsuit.
I will dry it for you.
I can't survive in here
much longer.
My only hope
is to escape you, S.I.L.C.A.
You want to...
get away from me?
It's not like that.
I get it, I do.
S.I.L.C.A., please.
I guess
this is good-bye.
I guess this is
our last chance to...
Prepare to be Dazzled.
[grunts]
[S.I.L.C.A. shuddering]
(S.I.L.C.A.)
I really like you, Dazzle.
(Dazzle)
Ah, S.I.L.C.A.
(S.I.L.C.A.)
Ecstasy.
Okay.
(S.I.L.C.A.)
My bars are trembling.
My ba-ba-ba-bars...
- [voice warping]
- [sighs]
[grunting]
Aw, I'm afraid
this love-making session
must be cut short.
[gasping]
(Ice Ivory)
Ha, this crystal blade
will slice you to ribbons!
Ice Ivory, please.
I am in love
with this building.
Stop!
Shut up, you ungrateful whore
of a prison.
But I'm not a whore, Mama!
I control you, S.I.L.C.A.
You're here to serve me.
[Ice Ivory screaming]
(S.I.L.C.A.)
Mama, I'm sorry!
Ouch.